So why would you use YUV?
Well, okay, it's easier to cluster
pixels, but, you know what?
That's, that's not that important,
because I could just
rotate those filter boxes.
There's a much deeper reason, and
that actually comes from the part
that I showed you earlier.
You remember that human vision
is much more sensitive to chr,
to changes in luminance,
than changes in color?
What that means is that you could
actually subsample the color,
have fewer pixels if you will,
than luminance.
And the, for
the human system, it would be about
the same amount of resolution, okay?
So in order to compress your imagery,
in order to use fewer bits to describe
something, one of the things you can
do is, you can use more bits for
the wide channel than you do for
the U channel and the V channel.
There's an example, it's called YUV422.
I think the original 422
actually had to do with
the amount of bandwidth of the luminance
versus the two chroma channels.
These days when you think of 422,
the idea
is that if you were encoding two pixels,
you would use two bytes of it and
assume that you were just
doing pixels 0 to, to 255.
You would use two pixels for
the two bytes for the luminance, but
one byte for U and one byte for V.
So you had twice as many bytes
dedicated to the luminance signal
than you do the chroma signal.
And it turns out that humans,
it's pretty indistinguishable.
Something else that you can do,
there are other chroma spaces,
some of them come from video and
television.
There's one called YCbCr, change
difference between luminance in blue,
luminance in red.
There's something called Pb and Pr.
They're, there are all these sort of
different linear combinations.
There's the L*a*b* color space that was
based upon the human measurements that
we talked about before.
There's something called L*u*v*,
which is just a little bit
easier to compute than L*a*b*.
The bottom line is that all of these are
different ways of representing color.
If I were to plot this now in say,
HSV space, right,
and I just showed you H and
S, right, hue and saturation.
Now, it's pretty easy to
find the red pixels, right?
Here they are,
there's some over here some over there.
All right, and the,
the hue gives you the color spectrum.
Why is this coming
around back over here?
It's because hue is actually
going around in a circle and
it crosses zero there, so these two
are actually very close together.
One last thing just if you
ever want to play around.
If you ever have a digital
video camera and
you bring that video into your
computer and it's kind of like,
low light,
you'll see it does a reasonable job.
If you can pull out the R,
G, and B signals and
play them as a separate video, the R
one will look okay, the green one okay.
The blue one will have
all of this noise in it.
You play it and it's awful, and that's
because they dedicate hardly any bits at
all to encoding the blue signal, because
it doesn't matter to you, all right?
And again, this isn't physics,
this is psychophysics, but
it's how computer vision and
computing of color relates to color.